Kevin Ryan H fly the ru garbage podcast
first time in studio thank you guys for
coming in what's up man thanks for
having us thanks for having us buddy I'm
in Australia right now this is coming
out in a week and travel I will be in
Australia have you gone to Australia yet
not yet it's a 15-hour flight I that's
what I hear it's 15 hours it's blood
clot Central Widow Maker Widow
Widowmaker air um two pairs of
compression socks for that flight I get
up and I walk in the middle of it and
the people like the flight attendant
will be like what are you doing I go I'm
trying to
survive I don't want to stroke out yeah
I'm trying to I get off this plane with
both sides of my body
operational but it's it's uh it's a
great country to do standup comedy in
but it's a long [__] flight yeah
you're Go I mean you've been you were
there not too long ago as well I that's
also a mistake you can't go back
immediately
because the people go we get it we know
what you do we're we're aware but yeah
we're doing well we got Sydney is sold
out Melbourne is on its way uh then
Brisbane and then the other ones we're
doing Auckland New
Zealand um I we we canceled Christ
Church I thought more tickets would sell
because that's where they had that
shooter did that
Manifesto so I really was hopeful about
Christ Church and I said to my team I go
we're going to be okay with Christ
church because that guy what did you
shoot up a synagogue yeah I go listen
I'm just saying they're wild so maybe
we're getting and I'm not for any of
that behavior I'm just saying I think
we're going to move some tickets we did
not which makes me happy yeah it's a
good reflection it makes me actually
very happy that uh those people are not
coming you know so uh I I I love you
gentlemen everybody knows you garbage
podcast you are the best new podcast in
the world thank you buddy means a lot
true um I wanted you guys on around this
even though it's warm out in New York
today which [__] me up I like the fall
to be the fall love it love the fall
right the best it's a little hot a
little too much I went swimming
yesterday in the ocean really yeah where
at out in the Hampton out Southampton
yeah in the ocean October Atlantic
City's out the godamn I don't know I
don't know what this guy Galveston Texas
and swam in the waters of the the oil
water um but I I want to talk about
Halloween with you guys because I know I
know that it's is it the trashiest
holiday or no it ain't the classiest
I'll tell you that it's definitely not
the [__] classiest it's the greatest
it is amazing many Snickers let's go as
two dirt two fat dirt bags who don't
like candy and [__] Mischief you know
what I mean yeah what where do you put
the holidays from from classy to Trashy
because that's kind of interesting do
you go Christmas as the classiest
because you get the candle in the window
and Christmas can go south not our not
our Christmas what are you talking about
Christmas can go south real quick nice
fight on Christmas morning yeah yeah
we're uh I think Christmas can be the
class if you're going Catholic H like
Easter to me there's no like real
boozing on Easter it's Sunday afternoon
you go to church Easter stinks it stinks
but that's the classiest I'll tell you
right now here's how we can ruin that
horseshoes my family during Easter at my
Aunt se's house sh God rest this is why
I have the top rated episode which just
pass a million by way I know Shane and
seura are are climbing on me I know it
but I'll tell you this my aunt C God
Rest her soul and her husband Uncle Bill
was a cop was that SHO Justified hey
now why you bringing up old [__] Split
Second decisions no they were they were
good it was a different time yeah they
were good people and uh you know they
had Easter Sunday and my family would
drink and then throw horseshoes Jes and
so there there would be kids running
around and then you'd have a metal
horseshoe like whizzing by your head and
like you'd be in your church you know
and then like you know somebody would
scream at you be like get on flat away
yeah and sling a throwing metal through
the but I agree with you in theory
there's nothing classier than Easter
yeah but it sucks and I always thought
in horseshoes that I wasn't good at it
cuz I didn't have a cigarette hanging
out of my mouth that's what I thought
that's what I thought made the uncles
that good it was a heiney you had to
have a hinin and a Sig hanging out of
the mouth in the throw you had to have
that you had to have it and they were
and they they played horseshoes during
Easter Sunday and then Easter Saturday
we would do my nanny would do a a pink
ham and she'd with a mustard vinegar
glaze MH okay which was real nice and
then she would do uh you know the sides
and stuff yeah when they when those
Honey Baked started getting popular the
game that's a big deal that was like
we're going to get the honey baked the
spiral cut cheese potatoes little
cinnamon apples yes yeah of course but
I'll tell you why Easter can kick rocks
one pastels K the [__] out of here
interesting I hate that [__] interesting
H fullet coming out against pastel t
foliage early early on in the
episode church is nice on uh Church on
Christmas no but I'm just saying you
know you have you have something nice on
it's the winner you're not going inside
you're hanging out in the back you're
goofing around you know what I mean you
maybe got a couple M&M's or some it's
not as proper it feels yeah dude [__]
Easter you feel like you're a used car
salesman I'm walking around in a pink
Blazer like a dick get out of here with
I will tell you one thing about Easter
there's what the the Easter cigarette
outside of the church oh nice grass is
coming
in little bit of a breeze little bit of
Breeze you're still sweating you're
still sweating but the sweat's being
cooled by the breeze and you're having a
Siggy outside the church and the priests
they're all looking at you go I know
what I'm doing but I'm here I'm on the
property I'm here I'm on the property
they were always waiting to rip a heater
that's remember the first time you saw a
priest ripping a ripping a
uhhuh behind the rectory holy [__] yeah
he's like I got to have something you
know so Easter I think you're right
about that Easter does the the cand is
whack too it presents as the classic I
don't like the candy and I don't like
you know the the Easter egg hunt the
basket hey hey hey what are we working
for here just I know you got to give it
to me there was only one that had a five
in it you know my aunt used to hide
these baskets so aggressively that
people would start crying me and my
cousins would start crying uh there was
no baskets she would hide them in places
my grandfather had did well and he built
his own house in in mutton toown Long
Island which is an area where Jennifer
Lopez mutt Town doesn't sound nice mut
sounds behind a butcher no I know but
it's it's one of those things rich
people do where they're like you you'd
think it's not but it's it's stunning
and he had a 5,000 foot house which toss
was huge the big house and but here's
the problem when you hide
baskets kids start crying because you
look in a few places and people start
getting upset now and my aunt really
liked that cuz she was sick demented
yeah she didn't have children herself
and and when we people would start to
cry and she would just go look look look
harder work harder and we run up and
down the stairs and then we'd eventually
find it and then what was the treat
nothing you know couple of pastel you
know you get a nice um Reese's duck I
mean Reese's what what is it those are
the peeps Reese's egg peeps can kick
[__] rocks Reese's egg the cadburry I
do like a cadburry cream cadry Cream Egg
love them a Cadbury Cream McFlurry in
London is nice holy [__] you doing that
over there welcome to the world oh
welcome to Global I got to get a
passport that's all right yeah it's not
bad and uh the candy didn't catch up
until recently when I was when we were
kids it was the shitty low low low
offbrand chocolate bunnies that were
Hollow wax wax chocolate and it was
chemical taste sucks you had a chemical
taste plus I remember was it a Russell
Stover what what kind of bunny did you
get Russell Stover I'd be all right with
Russell Stover was the one that was kind
of midgrade yes midgrade respectable
your father still has a job you got a
Russell Stover he got a Bonus that year
lint is a little Next Level lint who was
getting lint that's I didn't have that I
didn't have that till 32 a touch of sea
Sal sea Sal about it the lint bunny is a
nice bunny H the lint bunny is a good
bunny I remember one year getting a
solid white chocolate crucifix and I was
like can I see if you can even find can
I eat I would love to see a solid white
chocolate can I eat this crazy that was
definitely something they gave out to
for The Clue clux Clan by the way it's
real it's real I love you can get a
white chocolate crucifix how do you feel
about the white chocolate oh s I'm a fan
here's what I like I love it I like it
in ice cream my favorite flavor in hodas
is a white chocolate raspberry truffle
ice cream that's good when gadiva had
their ice creams and they were only
around for a few years in the Glory Days
of the late 90s the early a early 2000s
they had a white uh chocolate raspberry
ice cream white chocolate raspberry in
ice cream might be one of the greatest
flavor combinations but as an actual
candy I don't like it the only one that
kind of hangs in there is the Hershey's
cookies and cream of course that's a
little different though it was so classy
to me it was so like you get it once a
year when it comes I love it was I think
looking back I don't know if I love the
taste but I love the idea of it there's
a pageantry to Easter the flowers the
church and stuff it it is in theory
classy so we put that at number one
we're ignoring by the way uh is Islamic
and Jewish holidays here not because
we're not inclusive but I don't have any
experience do you gentlemen no I do not
we don't have any experience with
Ramadan or I was always uh jealous of my
Jewish friends on Christmas day that got
to go get Chinese in a movie though I
say that all the time but it's sad yeah
I don't there's sad I didn't think so I
thought it was under the radar and chill
no lines and a nice Chinese
restaurant Chinese restaurant you can do
that on a Tuesday afternoon go catch a
movie and Chinese food it's something
that we would do they do it then as like
a they got nothing else going on that's
right it's actually a little sad yeah I
loved it it's a little sad but I I will
say that like little kungpow chicken and
Saving Private Ryan well there's nothing
wrong there's nothing wrong with that
let's go shout out to dday there's
nothing wrong with a little kungpow
chicken or you know you got to remember
like you know that being first of all
that that had to be amazing when movies
were amazing MH when you were like a big
Blockbuster doing m in The Mask right
like like like oh we're going to see Ace
Ventura too like when movies were now I
feel like it's not as you know what I
mean people are probably doing it at
home like how we'll get take out and
watch and throw on [__] that no no I
want a nice Chinese restaurant where
they put the uh the crispy noodles on
the table in a bowl the good ones not
the ones in the [__] bag no the good
ones the good duck sauce and the good
hot mustard and then you go out to the
big screen and you see something good
yeah all I agree with you there is
Christmas the de facto
second I I
mean Christmas can be very very TR this
Christmas on aru garbage was one of the
first one of the first questions we ever
came up with was what color were the
lights on your house or your tree yeah
it could swing so hard way class that's
correct colored lights yikes Easter
everybody's got to kind of show up
somewhat proper
agree Christmas has declined in my house
hold so much MH that I have first of all
the prevalence of sweatpants and
sweatsuits it's and slippers and
Snuggies and weird like Comfort Leisure
wear has is insane yeah and the who
cares attitude about the food and the
presentation is troubling yeah you're
not wrong it's because a lot of these
Boomers have checked out you know they
my grandmother was a great cook my nanny
was a great cook these people were out
there making prime rib MH cream of
broccoli first thing in the morning
cooking you after presents they get at
it they start going day these Boomers
about 45 minutes before people
come take a [__] round to Xanax and
then throws cheese on a platter store
bought cheddar cheese on a platter with
some Triscuits and then God only knows
where we're going from there the chicken
the Chick-fil-A nugget tray right has
ruined this country ruined I got I got
to put my foot down on that they
fantastic you're crazy once that started
showing up in Philly then the soft
pretzel tray showed up soft PR I will
tell you this I love it great I'm not
saying they're not great it's nice but
when they when they chart the decline of
this Empire yeah the soft pencil you're
not dude he's getting mentioned oh my
God you bring me here and do this to me
soft penel is just there's nowhere to go
from there that's that's going to be
positive no well so Philly Soft Pretzel
is a company Philly Soft Pretzel Company
I'm well aware sure for the listeners
for in the midwest he owns 30% not my
part owner he's got three
locations I just open one out of
Hampton oh that'd be great dude it would
be great that's what you need to do you
need to start doing that content
purposes alone the three of us should
open a soft a Philly Soft Pretzel
Company no it' be amazing and it would
be get Aras in the H it would be the
shout out to Ras by the way I love Reas
but it would be the best episode of
Undercover Boss cuz immediately they'
all be like oh get these [__]
three of us we all have fake mustaches
on and [__] we're like how long youing
what's folio like what's a
pretzel we don't know oh you dip it in
the cheese okay that's good to know what
uh but you're you're saying it's so the
so the pretzel tray uh I just had it was
uh Labor Day weekend my brother's house
I got there early the pretzel tray we
brought the pretzel tray we stopped at
it sat on my lap the whole ride over to
the car dude I was salivating and you
could feel it on the thigh yeah and it's
the Nugget salt mhm you feel ass salt
and it's on the thigh I would be lying
if I we cracked it open in the car I
went out with Ray comp and his wife
after my mother's funeral to a bar in
Long Beach called The
Saloon and we were sitting in the saloon
and we got the soft prenzel tray with
the cheese in the middle and it is nice
it's awesome it is nice communal it
brings people together it really does um
but now that the dips they have the
cheese dip like do they have they have
they have
cinnamon that will blow your [__]
hair back now I'm I'm kind of liking
that on paper you look at it you're like
d I don't know if dude one little dip of
that day is changed for the better it's
fantastic I like that and you could even
go back a couple of years years with the
cinnamon on that same tip what started
to go downhill remember when the fruit
tray started to get a little popular but
it wasn't just the fruit tray remember
the cream cheese yes whipped cream dip
in the center yes yes but all that stuff
the reason I say it's the downfall of
the of the Empire is that's replacing a
homemade dip that's replacing something
that you're grandmother used to do
absolutely we and we're riding to slide
down I'm not I'm not complaining there
was always an aunt who came with nothing
but a dip this woman did not exist
except to walk through the door with
that you didn't care about her you
didn't care what she said she smoked
sigs in the back people were like hey
like it was no one cared she had coke
bottle glasses she would walk in but
she'd walk in either with like in the
Northeast she'd walk in with a clam dip
M yeah she might walk in with a seven
layer dip a seven layer Mexican dip we
were a big taco dip we called it taco
dip whatever you want to call it buffalo
chicken dip yeah so This Woman's walking
in with a dip she has nothing she has no
children no kids a small old dog she has
a tiny dog she has nothing in her life
she makes that dip once a year and she
walks into the house and and her only
social interactions on this entire
planet Are People Like Us going you
bring the dip and she goes of course I
did and she smiles and then we smile mhm
and that's and then for the other 364
days year she's dead she just sits in
her house and she watches soap operas
and drinks and takes pills cuz her life
is horrible but that moment when she go
when we go did you bring the dip and her
name's always like it's Rey or something
yeah it's right a Rey's here with the
taco dip it's two syllables and it makes
no sense I have to say my mom is Aunt
nie with the taco dip I swear to God I
swear to hey ni you doing a taco dip and
that dip is important and you're right
now those people that we know that that
dip was their life they've died off a
little bit they've died off a little bit
or do they just show up with the because
it's not as nice when you're just
bringing the pencils no but it's also
like oh I'm going to invest three hours
I'm going to the store I forgot I got to
go back to that's a that's an afternoon
to make the taco dip to make the buffalo
chicken dip to whatever or you go on the
way over I'm going stop at this soft
pretzel the Chick-fil-A spend 20 bucks
and we're I CH the downfall of my family
parties my aunt started making dirt she
started doing dirt in a in a pale in an
actual pale yeah in the we used to do
them in like those Clay Pot like those
plastic Potters she would do it in a
pale gummy worm and and she would put
the you know the the what is it the
Jello pudding it's like yeah it's
Jello-O it's Jello-O pudding the gummy
worms gmy worms the crushed Oreo or
whatever that started a decline of
that is very tough
to uh you know describe other than to
say that that was the beginning maybe
the end of my family yeah I remember the
first time I had that it was uh a
luncheon after a funeral that was in a
public park under an awning things were
going I swear to God that was the first
time I saw that I was like what is that
was it a funeral for a driveby and they
they explained it to me and I was like
holy [__] that's genius we ate it with a
shovel
we had the shovels scooped it out with
the shovel we had the shovels yeah I
mean absolutely that blew my brains
about so to to me that was a big thing
but Christmas you're right it can go bad
and I've seen it go bad yeah do you
start mixing boo especially with my
we're a big booze family you mix in
booze and the emotions are high emotions
are high there's a everybody spent a
[__] ton of money that month cuz Easter
you don't even feel like it's a holiday
no there's no presents Christmas you're
like you and never there for me all of
those emotions come Rush between
Thanksgiving and Christmas those
holidays those are holidays where you're
the pressure red lining it's right it's
it's running through your veins credit
cards are maxed out God you didn't get
what you want you and the wife were figh
what the kid how are you going to pay
kids are ungrateful all that [__] the
rich the rich side of the family just
kind of shoves it in your face yeah
little by little yeah that would that
would start up in our family uh on the
Friday after Thanksgiving cuz on the
Friday after Thanksgiving five car loads
of our would all head up to the King of
Prussia Mall for the big day of shopping
for the Black Friday sales you e it to
food court you know what I mean you'd
say tell your parents what you want it
and all this stuff then you would leave
at your Aunt they'd run in and get it
real quick are you a is it a bourbon
chicken are you a ranch one chicken and
cheese at what uh
theia what are you doing we used a Walk
and Roll I used to love Walk and Roll
nothing wrong with that I was a sabaro
man loved it still do and by the way
I've eaten it in New York City
I I you want to hear something you want
to hear you want to hear something when
I was a tour guide in New York City
uhhuh let me tell you about
sad okay I'm gonna tell you right now
something that I feel like it's it's
it's it's tough to even admit and come
out of my mouth Time Square sabaro
breakfast buffet whoa when I was a tour
guide in new yor what that looking like
not good what are those what are those
those home fries the hash brown patties
Frozen patties which you like I love I
love and what you do is you take a Patty
you put a little scramble uhhuh bacon
and then you put the Patty on top you
make a little hash brown sandwich and I
would do it never thought that they had
look there it is look at that New York
there it is go to the third picture over
there it is that's the part of the
sabaro breakfast buffet they had a
literal breakfast buffet in Time Square
that you could eat and I would eat there
uh sometimes before my tour before I
would give tours in New York City on the
tour bus holy [__] that that had to slow
you down a little bit let me tell you
right now that first tour was real phun
in not a lot of tips on that one yeah no
I sometimes I would do the tour I'd
literally get on the bus and I would go
Hell's
Kitchen and they'd go what and I go
Hell's Kitchen and I'd go Central Park
Central Park uh and then other scr egg
burp yeah I would just be like sometimes
you try to hit a Bernie on the bus with
no one seeing really yeah you this is
why I love you like a baseball manager
in go to the back maybe there's six
maybe there's six people on the bus
maybe they're Russians Russians are
great they're not they're not rats they
like they're not rats Americans are rats
by their [__] nature you give me a
family from Ohio you give me a woman
named Donna you're getting ratted out a
woman named [__] [__] Ivanka or you
know or or her husband Oleg they don't
care she wants a drag she wants a drag
she's maybe hitting one you go to the
back you just like this you know you
hide it yeah you pal it and you Palm it
and then you just keep it to the side
dude that's crazy you get a few and then
you toss it off the bus and then you
keep going you know awesome yeah I mean
so Christmas can go really bad I think
the the well decorate Christmas is one
of the things you really decorate the
house for right so like right away if
that's bad that's a real big indicator
of what you're doing if the lights are
just like kind of thrown across the bush
in the front you can see the extension
cords things are flickering there's like
that's going to be a that's going to be
a rough Christmas inside you got to have
white lights white lights you got to
have white lights on the tree or color
lights can be done very well like kitchy
like oh it's like a homage back to the
fucking' 60s or whatever but it's got to
be done real like right the one thing
that does class up Christmas and this is
depending on different families and
stuff like that if there was the uncle
and the aunt that didn't have kids that
did well that showed up Christmas day
that had a stack of money holders in
their breast pocket and everybody was
getting broken off with a f a crisp 50
when you opened a card from your
grandparents and saw a $100 cash or
something that was you were you were
like start playing the market let's go
etic ecstatic because that was like the
best present I had my Aunt Kate was uh
exec at a big company in Philly cash no
kids I was her godson just broken off
see that's the guy that I kind of will
be because I don't have kids so it's
like here's the money you boom here you
go here's an extra everybody's getting
50 you get two I was like there's
something really nice about um when a
family gets it like my family now the
kid all of the cousins have gotten older
but nobody's had
kids nobody had as populated so I always
said this as you get older the holidays
unless there are children they get
sadder yeah you know they got keep fresh
blood and
uh what happens is people just start it
just is sad and this is happen people
start talking about cell phones like
people have sit on a sectional and this
is one of the
enough
saboros [__] piz I'm out of the
office this week with strep throat I
hope you guys are enjoying this episode
with the ru garbage boys uh and
hopefully the Middle East uh you know
calms down um but I want to talk about
blue chew right now because I've talked
about it for seven years and that must
mean I love it blue chw is a pill that
you can take to make your penis hard and
it has the same active ingredients is
Viagra and
Calis um but it's in a chewable form and
and you can get it prescribed online
there's no embarrassing doctor visits or
bumping into somebody that you know at
the drugstore because they will ship it
to you in a discret package so you don't
have to explain to your roommate or
other members of your family what's
going on with your
penis bluechew is good so if you go to
bluechew.com and use promo code TD it
checkout you're going to get your first
month free that's crazy go to blue.com
use promo code TD at checkout you're
going to get your first month
free uh and that is a big deal and again
I'm out of the office with strep throat
I'm hoping everything is going well and
I hope that uh from the Ukraine to
Israel to the Gaza Strip to all of these
places that we can all kind of just cut
it out cut it out and stop being
Knuckleheads as my uh Nanny would say
stop being dodo bird and
Knuckleheads and get the blue Chu for
your penis people sit on a sectional and
start talking about cell phones and cell
phone service and you start say I can't
get any at the house you start right you
start going maybe there is no God maybe
this is pointless how do you turn the
ringer off it keeps ringing I don't know
how it is you know what I do yeah they
all got a tip on it well she's on our
family plan now as soon as the words
family plan come out man I go I'm out
I'm leaving I don't this is a this is
nothing this is less than nothing this
is a conversation people would have on a
on a public bus somewhere elevator
you're right it's elevator talk we don't
we we're family and no one cares about
anything that's when I have to go and
Christmas has now become you see these
people they're strangers when you have a
divorced family like I do yeah you're
sitting next to people you don't know
who they are sure I don't know who my
aunt my
Stepmother's brother's niece is yeah so
I'm sitting next to people I have no
idea who they are that's tough and
that's what happens sometimes in a in a
family of divorce yeah because now
you're sitting at a table with strangers
although I will say this my my
Stepmother's uh her her sister-in-law
Libby does a shrimp scampy will change
her life yeah D Li's all right and she
does and she does you know why because
she uses garlic
powder not a clove has ever seen nice
she just garlic powders that [__] like
I mean it's crazy and it's like fentanyl
it's just really really good and you
just eat like a pound of it and then
you're coma toast and you're on some
sectional in a basement of a house and
then they then they just start going in
about like well I I'm
AT&T I have eight Tim is you know Tim is
AT&T to it just gets Tim they have AT&T
in LA like yeah right that's how bad it
gets so you still get the unlimited
minutes you're right I envy the
families that almost have a tragedy now
where it's like somebody went to jail
where you can talk about that like if
there's one guy who's not there because
he's serving time we can speak about him
it's at least a topic it's a topic it's
real I envy the families who at least
have someone to talk about who's
destroyed their life and instead of cell
service or like traffic that's another
thing how you getting home how'd you get
here traffic's crazy we go down the
shore every summer and it's right when
you get down you get down on a Friday
when you get down when you leaving how
did you get do you take the W Whitman
it's that's it's traffic would it be
better if we all had some somebody to go
you know you know uh you know we we
we're going to visit him soon we're
going to visit him soon you you know
he's doing you gone yet he's doing what
he has to do like I was at my mother's
funeral and uh did they say anything to
you about Ronnie about what happened or
anything like that they did they talk to
you you know you're in the line getting
the scampy what did they say I I didn't
really hear anything about it have you
heard from him I my mother's funeral
this guy comes out to me he goes he goes
hey he goes I dated your mother back in
the day I was like if my mother was like
hot back in the day so I was like oh I
don't want to okay thanks who said this
to you this guy my mother's funeral
[__] Long Island front of the we're
right [__] me we're right in front of
the ear we got her created she's in the
ear and we're sitting there she's got
this beautiful collage ofly car on boats
and her doing Florida things and you
know I'm sitting there and a guy comes
up to me he goes he goes I dated your
mother back in the day and I go uh I go
oh he goes yeah you know my Jimmy I'm
not gonna say his last name he goes I'm
Jimmy and he goes you know my son James
I go yeah how's he do and he goes not
good oh immediately he goes not good I
go okay like find a leave it at that
find a leave it at at that but they
never are he goes yeah he goes he's got
drug problems and he's got mental
problems so he's in the hospital right
now and he's standing there with his
wife he goes he's in a hospital right
now but he goes uh he sends his regards
he goes like this no no swear to God he
goes but he knows you he goes he knows
you and he like watches your stuff and
he goes he's in the hospital right now
and he's trying and that's our attitude
if he tries we'll try and then he looked
at me and goes like this he goes you own
something in the Hamptons I heard
he might be looking for a room when he
gets out he pretty nice out there huh it
was just the way he said it he goes he's
in the hospital when he tries we'll try
you some out east time that's not it's
just like one guy said to me walking out
my mother's funeral he goes he goes
blessing in disguise now like that's
Jesus Christ this guy that owned a surf
shop he go blessing this guy because
Long Island you you you have to
understand the death of a family member
usually comes with some type of check
sure it comes with an inherited house
house it comes maybe with a few tiffany
lamps I never thought of that these
people in Long Island they live to
inherit and once they've inherited they
then immediately start complaining about
the taxes they have to pay on what they
inherited they're they're just you know
like immediately they inherit their
mother's house and then like the next
day they're like these [__] taxes
these immigrant this community's falling
apart so when he's like blessing and
disguise he was kind of funny because
he's like you know in all in Long Island
there's opportunity there's Cash There's
Cash There's a pay yeah there's there's
a deed there's a title getting
transferred but I saw these Boomers
walking into her uh funeral and I was
like it's just an amazing generation of
people you know they're just really
amazing think about from where they
started on this planet you know my
parents were born in
1952 they grew up during the 60s the
hippies
Woodstock now it's 202
23 okay the amount of technological
change in that period of time I I don't
know that there's any generation that
has experienced that in the way that
these people have true at the age they
were yeah at the age they were to see
how different things are you know and to
be able
to go on all of these different
applications and still be
racist and still keep the old ideas and
the old value system through every new
from Facebook to tick tock they are not
dissuaded like the fear and the paranoia
that they just have just to be able to
like spread that on every new and they
can barely use these things but they can
use them well enough they can get a
status up they can get some they can get
a couple of words up and it's just one
of those things where holidays I think
have become less interesting
because you know what all the people are
doing sure you know what they're doing
and you know what they think I have that
like it's also like you know
everything's been so political like we
were talking about over the past five
years or whatever and it's like you'll
go somewhere and like the second a
conversation starts why everybody's
hanging we're at the we're at the island
and we're eating and we're drinking and
laughing and breaking balls and then
someone's like did you see this and I'm
like ruin I'm out cuz like my family is
90 I'm not that I'm I don't I'm in I'm
neutral I'm in the middle I don't give a
[__] about
repblic so it's like but it's like
here's the deal there's no reason on the
on the on the salad line sure you should
hear to name George Floyd sure there's
zero reason and they don't even
pronounce his name right like one of my
uncles once was like this uh you know
George uh George and then somebody's
like from the other room George Floyd po
were waiting for it George Floyd I go no
one has to yell the name George Floyd
throughout the house while we're putting
meatballs on the play yeah with the
alley hoop coming in have you been down
have you been down to the city lately no
you're going down there what are you
crazy n it's nuts it's riots every night
it turns so quick it turns very quick
and it's like they want they want it
they get excited when the political
people come to the party oh they're
they've prepared talking points well
there's a fuse lit the second they're in
the door you're like is it 2 minutes is
it 10 minutes 3 hours I don't know when
it is but it's [__] happening and I'm
getting called [__] real quick it's
coming out and they're just like very
they're ready to pounce and it happens
from both sides cuz my aunt is very
liberal and she likes to get into it too
like we she was out east at the house
and it's beautiful out and it's nice and
every you know my cousin's kids are in
the pool like everybody's doing okay
there's no there's no reason for any of
this and she's just sitting there and
she's just eating food and she just
looks up from her lobster roll and she's
like when when are they going to put
Donald Trump in jail and I'm like can
you just eat your [__] lobster roll
can you eat your for Christ can you eat
your [__] lobster roll $20 lobster
roll 20 come on it's crazy out there
it's $80 a pound it's stupid exact it's
stupid they just eat it but it's just
they cannot help themselves because
they're before they got there they were
at home for an hour and a half on some
old laptop at the at the island in the
kitchen just going through Facebook and
it's this and it's that and it's Lantern
flies and it's they're they're just
going nuts people used and you know what
I think is interesting is people used to
have intra family
feuds and they would be about real
things like they'd hate each other over
something that made sense now maybe it
was silly maybe it was ridiculous you
know a famous one is like grandma died
the house got sold somebody felt
swindled money my family doesn't talk to
nobody because of money money's a big
one sometimes it's a thing someone got
something in an inheritance somebody
should somebody didn't go to somebody
else's Christmas or kids birthday party
I respect that I respect that you you're
personally attacked or you feel
personally the real world you didn't
visit her at the nursing home we were
out there every Sunday yes now people
fight over politics which is the
craziest thing to me they hate each
other because of politics which is not
not
affecting them really other than dayto
day yeah their dayto day other than they
like the idea of of of having moral
superiority over the other people we
used to have when I was growing up it
was this bear this snuggy you know the
uh detergent yeah of course Huggy Bear
right yeah I I forget hugy bear snuggles
star SK Snuggles the Bear the bear okay
so Snuggles the Bear and my cousins
I had this snuggles and I kind of gave
it to them but I didn't really give it
to them something had happened or
whatever and yeah it looked exactly like
that it's kind of creepy now that I see
it you had a laundry detergent bear I
had a snuggle bear and then my aunt we
would all me and my cousins would fight
over this bear fist fight over the bear
and then my aunt at the end of the party
would go to my grandfather like can I
have the be e a AR because she was
taking it for them they were German
nothing wrong with that but let's just
it is what it is and they you know they
believed in certain things and uh this
was a big strain on our family that my
family felt like they had stolen this
bear from me and gave it to their Nazi
kids okay and things like that started
feuds of course dumb things like that
would start Feud and I respect it you
know I remember during the Fourth of
July one year mhm my my my someone
called my uncle's wife a Jew my Aunt
Dawn whose last name was Hassan but she
was maybe a little Arab she had a nose
thing was it followed up with by she
knows what I mean come on it was one of
those was like let's not went up it's
fine but wait they're good people I work
with one it was that crazy so then he's
like [__] all of you I'm going to leave
and drive home and he was hammered so my
uncle my uncle and my other Uncle went
out and took the air out of his car they
flattened all his tires so he couldn't
leave Jesus aggressive but effective
aggressive but effective this was Fourth
of July me and the kid who lived up the
block were sitting I was sleeping at at
their house they were like best friends
with my uncle's family so we all got to
stay over there the all the adults were
just getting hammered we were watching
this whole thing from like a house down
watching my uncles take the air out of
my other uncle's car so he couldn't
drive away and then my grandfather got
up cuz then they wouldn't stop and my
grandfather was famous for doing this
he's done it a few times he would like
get up and go
downstairs and knock somebody out and
then just go to bed damn so my uncle my
uncle was getting really crazy this was
another holiday and he was just spouting
and being nuts and my my grandfather
came down just laid him out went right
back to bed and then the next day my
uncle was like who knocked me out my
grandfather was like I did my my uncle
was like thank you I needed that and he
goes you know anytime but he was like a
pil boxer like an Irish boxer would just
and so we had a violent kind of drunken
yeah I come from that that's there's
fist fights close to fist fights once a
year easily right so why can't we get
back to that I'm out of the office with
strep throat this week and I hope you
guys are enjoying uh the podcast with
the ru garbage boys love those
guys um many people don't know the story
about when I tried to get tickets to the
Taylor Swift concert but I was desperate
and I started prostituting my body
to get tickets to it because I couldn't
afford them and I didn't understand
these scalpers and these websites and I
was prostituting
myself and it was hard but I kept doing
it for about three months in hopes that
I could afford to see Taylor Swift at uh
I forget where but one of the places she
was
going so
maybe and I I am a Prost I became a
prostitute because of it and I have
AIDS and AIDS is not a big deal as much
because you can survive with AIDS for
very long time although it is awkward to
bring
up
um and it's not even HIV is full-blown I
fullblown this which is not which is
still is
bad
and because I wanted to see that concert
so badly I fullblown AIDS because I was
prostituting myself and I would let
anyone do anything to me for any amount
of money scat piss [__] blood play any
of it any of it do you know how much I
love Taylor Swift when you're getting
just [__] by people you don't even
know because one guy I would have he
would wear a mask and hold a gun to my
head and I would only I would just be on
all fours and he would just come in and
I would see him in the mirror with the
mask on he would hold a gun to my head
which he said wasn't loaded I hope it
wasn't and then he would leave and it
was you know I don't know if he gave me
AIDS but there was another way to do
this and I wish I had known about this
app earlier and it was the game time app
and they have last minute tickets Flash
Deals Zone deals easy to to find and buy
tickets for every kind of event in your
area views from allc to The Venue lowest
price guarantee event cancellation
protection job loss protection Etc and
that to me is exciting because you can
get the best tickets the best deals no
AIDS from this app you you just can do
it and if you download the game time app
create an account use the code Tim for
20% off $20 off your first purchase
download the game time app create an
account use the code Tim for 20% off
your first purchase you're gonna have a
much better life because you're not
going to be in a motel in Jersey with a
gun in your head getting peed and pooed
on so that you can go see Taylor Swift
you know but when I finally made it and
I was in that and she did love story
every time I was beaten by a trick every
time I was beaten by a trick and it was
a lot every time I was beaten by a trick
pissed on by a trick was worth it when I
heard her do love
story I would do it all again but you
don't have to go to the game time app
create an account use the code t for 20%
off your first purchase I well here's
what's happened I think what's actually
ruined all of this is Technology's kind
of ruined people because people are now
Angry all the time there's no they're
constantly they're constantly be
reinforced of like is what I believe
this is this article this is that so
angry yeah they're running hot that you
holidays used to be a special time
because people would drink alcohol and
then have this flood of emotions and see
each other now people just hate each
other all day every day it's like a Time
release adero versus doing a line of it
yeah I also think too right like you
said it's like you know there's this
booze is involved there's this release
of emotion and sometimes it's good
sometimes you would get out I [__]
love you you mean so much to me other
times it was bad you [__] stole my
you know whatever but then in the
morning or the next day you're
reconciled right like you're not
reconciling over a political argument
because you still feel you're right and
there's at least some sort of I'm sorry
I was [__] up last night I was out of
line that in like an Irish Catholic
Family is it's essential huge that's
huge it it's one of those things where
technolog is making people slowly less
human yeah and that's the unfortunate
thing Halloween was it the party route
for you how does it
uh no I mean as a kid it was suburbs
outside of Philly just hardcore
trick-or-treating like right you know
that was me but then you're man you know
you become a man that first year you
throw an egg this is why sure the first
year that my friends like kids like
Alfred kinesi was
popular he's maybe he's still popular I
don't know um seemed to be over it but
those kids Johnny madx Pat mccre when I
man yeah these were like kid great High
School great names great but this is
eighth grade great going to manx house
these were the cool kids and they were
and they were genuinely cool like that's
the thing about cool kids people like oh
are they cool yeah they're cooler than
you they are cool it's not a thing they
were much more fun to hang out with then
you
know my friends so they invited me and
we threw eggs and we shaving cream stuff
yeah was this Mischief Night did you do
you guys Halloween night Halloween night
Night Long Island is my first and I felt
like oh I'm growing up because I'm with
cool kids and we're throwing eggs and
we're vandalizing stuff this is what
cool kids you feel like you're in a
movie like you seen this before I'm not
trick-or-treating like a [__] sure I'm
not walking around with a Frankenstein
head and my mother I'm out there
defacing property with my friend and
that was it's an important night for
every now I don't know what they do now
they might do gang initiation now what
do they do no it's p are they still
vandalizing or is that even that's like
[__] now I don't know now they're like
swatting each other and having the feds
on the other end of that you know what
they're doing like my nieces and nephews
they don't go door too anymore oh
interesting trunker treat they call it
oh I don't like this so [__] whack
it's corny as [__] it's during the day
like maybe the day before or something
leading up they all drive to like the
you know the the football field in town
they Park their cars all around it open
up their trunks decorate their trunks
now why are they not going door too is
it because danger maybe I don't know
well you know what's interesting I think
it was a CO thing a lot of people don't
do it so a lot of houses you just knock
knock knock and nobody's home people are
like we're not doing it there used to be
only one or two of them and that's that
see that's like a that's how you knew
that was the creep of the neighborhood
right you never went by they never had
Christmas decorations or Thanksgiving
decorations and they didn't do anything
on Halloween that's how you knew to stay
away so when you're doing that [__] at
the at the football field now now you
you got no you got no judgment Trunk or
Treat we [__] insane they've been
doing it for a decade I'm telling you
and they pull up in a parking lot
everybody yeah and you like everybody
backs their car into like a make a big
you like a horseshoe shape yeah and then
you decorate the back of your car they
sell decorations for the back of your
car I don't like this and then so it's
safe everybody's parents are there if I
had children I would look get that up
get that up right now holy [__] holy God
I'd rather my kid kidnapped I'd rather
my kids kidnapped for a couple of days
for a couple of days than this this
ruins people's lives man God you got to
have Halloween cuz like you said you got
to have that right a
passage you got to go from the costume
to all of a sudden one year you have a
sweatshirt on maybe a mask and you got
the pillowcase once you cross over to
the pillowcase you didn't for that was
that was a lifechanging moment for you
it was a life changing moment for me
because that ain't happening in Trunk or
Treat you're not having a life changing
moment you're not learning anything at
trunk or tree something that happens
when you're a teenager you have to
decide which kind of teenager you're
going to be yes a good one or a bad one
I decided I was going to be a bad one I
didn't hurt people per se but I stole
money I did drugs you know I lied sure I
cheated you know when I could in school
um I didn't care about anything my main
goal from when I was 12 or 13 years old
till you know when I was in my really
mid 20s but let's just say for the teen
years my main goal was to make myself
happy MH and I liked marijuana cocaine
Percocet fadin I take a pill of morphine
if you had it i' do a line of caman I
take an ecstasy got parties dude with a
little Mitsubishi symbol in it I would
take not getting that a trunk or tree I
would take a tab of acid I'd take a
little sugar cube of acid with the blad
Little Red Dot acid in it I would take
remember the first time I saw that yeah
I'd take an ather shrooms I'd smoke a
Benson and hedges unfiltered if gentl if
we could steal it my friend's mother
Barb Barb I would do all these things
because they made me happy yeah sitting
in Oil City which was this area of just
oil drums it was abandon and smoking a
pack of maror lights that maror Reds
even that we stole from my friend's
mother and then puking made me happy mhm
those were the times those were the
times life may not ever get better than
that what scares me now is the drugs are
too intense that kids are dying y
because they can't have that fun that we
had they're dying now that little
experimentation goes quick it's quicker
it's a it's a shorter Road they're doing
fentin all now whatever it is now they
get to a point where it Alters their
light like I remember running around
Halloween throwing some eggs doing some
shaving cream smoking a little weed
stuff like that bad weed too stems and
seeds good take you know or you take you
take you do some psychedelics in your
teen years and I think you know that is
okay yeah I don't not 12 but like if
you're 17 or 18 and you and your buddies
take some
shrooms that's when you do it it's while
you do it that you got from the older
guy that works at the restaurant that
you work at but you had to drive a half
an hour to get it there was a there was
a process there was a process these are
problem solving those are life skills
yeah I see a lot of people that that
don't grow up now yeah see a lot of
people that don't grow up and it's weird
emotionally meaning they'll have an
apartment they'll have money they'll be
able to pay their bills but they're not
emotionally growing up they don't know
anything about the world they don't know
anything about people and I go how did
that happen uh how did that happen and I
think Technology's flattened everybody
to the point where a lot of people's
formative experiences are on the
internet and they're not in real life
with real people you learned a lot about
yourself disappearing into the Suburban
night with Johnny manx you're not
kidding you you had fun you had a good
time and you you you go okay we can't do
too much crazy [__] cuz we'll go to jail
right and we can't [__] with these kids
because they'll kill us yeah and we got
to learn to think like when me and my
friend Shay went to his Aunt Deb's house
in uh in Rockaway Breezy Point and we
knew you know you know she was a fun
woman she liked Fleetwood match she
enjoyed sangria sounds like a great lady
that's a combo right there I mean she's
an Irish woman she like to flipflop a
sangria and she liked putting the keys
in that
car firing it up she liked starting that
car she had like a Firebird something
fun she likes starting that car because
you know what who's you know who's
telling her what nobody you have a
couple of cocktails she likes she lik
that that sent and there's no room and
we just knew what we could get away we
knew what we could steal so we would
take some of her absolute vodka she
liked she liked she liked uh
well and we would take some some are
absolute we we do a couple of drinks and
then we we'd pour some water in it yeah
we do this these are you know what you
get away as long as that's not kept in
the freezer you're all right you're okay
you don't now kids today barricade her
in her bathroom with a gun steal her car
and go buy heroin take her 401K yes
that's not what you do that's too much
too that's too much you steal a little
bit of booze you get a little warmth you
go into the backyard you do a Bernie
it's fun people need to steal a little
bit yeah and what happened to that
everything now is like off the
chain I'm I'm take I just stole my
aunt's car I'm selling it and I'm buying
fenal that's too much because you can't
come back from that I feel like those
little those little uh those little
steps of like oh I am this I'm not that
guy I did that that was a little too
much I'm not that guy or Tim did that
that was too oh I'm not I'm not that guy
like you learn you got to be a little
bit of a [__] you got to keep yourself
on a leash because the guys that aren't
[__] die yeah that's true we know a
guy who's like dude that's the toughest
guy I've ever met and he's dead now I
know seven of them right right the
legitimate child Thief started out going
through the hall closet where the winter
coats were picking what what was finding
a five that's what that's what the
gentleman does that when when you have a
bunch of coats on bed during Christmas I
would start calling dealers at 10:30 at
night like hello
Chico God Rest yeah they just checked in
they'll be out for a couple hours come
by so to me I think uh what we're losing
is moderation you're not wrong you're
totally not wrong We're Not Gonna
nobody's going to be a saint and you
shouldn't be there's nothing funner than
doing the wrong thing in in you know
little little doses yeah yeah yeah with
some sort of caution with some sort of
wits about you of like all right that
you know and and now there there is no
it seems like there was always in every
High School class there was always five
kids 10 kids are like oh those kids are
[__] nuts they're the ones that are
crazy that end up dying or whatever now
it's like half the class is that kid
it's like that's why Thanksgiving which
is the last holiday we we really haven't
covered but Thanksgiving to me there's
something important the night before
Thanksgiving sure 100% this is
important here's what happens in my view
the night before Thanksgiving when when
you go away I didn't go away to college
I went to community college and then I
dropped out right but I remember I had a
friend who who was really tight and he
ended up going to Community College
sticking with it and then going to
Cornell which like a really good school
and then George Washington University
law school and I I felt very deeply
insecure because I was doing nothing
with my life you know what I mean it's
even out but the point is I'm doing all
right the first the first year you go
back to that bar for me it was the Black
Thorn R Center and you see all those
guys that you were buddies with you're
still kind of in it oh yeah you're still
in it that first year but every
subsequent year it's a you're a little
diminishes they're faces blur around the
edges it's very interesting that's why I
think it's important the first few years
after high school to go out yeah that
Wednesday night before Thanksgiving
because you should know what that feels
like to start to for the blurring to
start yeah for the for the separation
for the that's right and you also come
back and go like I I the same thing very
similar upbring in the suburbs and theth
and it was like we'd go to the pub and
you'd get there and there was the guy
who went straight to the pub from high
school yeah and the guy who went to
[__] duke or whatever or Harvard
right and you all come back and you're
like oh Steve you have you've been at
the pub all year right we just came back
this you're like okay I don't want to be
Steve puts things in perspective right
it's that little you find out who you
want to be and who you don't want to be
and then like as the group that the next
year gets a little if there's 10 guys it
comes to eight guys then five guy four
and it's like then it's just Steve and
the other Steves from the year prior
years sitting there drinking beers but
it's also a little bit of a dog show
those first couple of years you show up
representing you're peacocking a little
bit but then yeah it does go downhill
then the the owners changes the bar it's
not the Ben elbow anymore now it's
called mcgerks and it's this gks is all
right though the owner talking to you
now like you're an adult do you I knew I
was an alcoholic when owners of bar
started talking to me like an adult and
uh telling me about problems they were
having and I'm like I'm coming here to
get drunk with my friends we're still
like young we're still in our late teens
we can't handle all of this you know so
to me it's like those are important
moments that you need to have as as an
adult to become a fully functioning
adult and I think the holidays and the
activities around the holidays are
important and and I just hope that there
is
a recognition of that and that you know
we don't lose everything to the digital
world you know yeah because the local
bar is important very important very
important it can't all be a club it
can't all be a DJ it can't all be we're
going to see uh dip in Vegas respect to
him he follows me on Instagram enough
with the marathons we don't care do the
thing I ran a mar what do who my point
is this and marshmallow but I don't want
to start a beef with this other one
marshmallow I know that you're more
famous than me I don't know why but I
know that you do your whatever at s SW
Steakhouse right now at the wind Las
Vegas they are doing this their which is
one of my favorite restaurants they have
the lake of dream show a singing
cigarette smoking Frog who sings New
York New York while I eat the chili
rubber Rite which you got rid of you
shouldn't have but whatever they are now
serving a marshmallow cake marshmallow
who is apparently has some residency at
the wi uh love lovely SW Steakhouse my
favorite restaurant in Vegas marshmallow
has a residency at the wind they are
serving a marshmallow cake with his dumb
logo with the X's for the eyes and it's
the shape of that head he
wears stop this the marshmallow cake $40
Chris I'm not going to say your name but
we know who you are $40 Chocolate Moose
toasted marshmallow mering I'm a
nougatine number one how dare you not
send me one for free number two stop it
it's it's grot you have a cake of your
head that is not good for $40 is is it
never enough can you talk to these
people and say please stop doing this
it's crazy and moring can kick rocks
kick [__] get out here with that [__]
um but what I what I want to say what I
what I want to what I want to close on
is your show to me and the reason why I
love it the reason why a lot of people
love it it's hilarious thank you but
more important than that to me is that
like you're whether you realize it or
not you're
chronicling history this is [__] huge
you really truly I mean I think that's a
little lty we talk about mayonnaise and
peret but that is his listen there's
going to be a time there's going to be a
time when you talk about a mayonnaise
and peret sandwich yeah
people are going to go what's that so
but no it is true it's like I'm a big
fan of inflating our import our
importance all of us but uh I I listened
to your show and I remember [__] that's
now lost literally true [__] that you
it's lost it's a Chronicle of of a Time
Gone by it's a Time Gone by that you'll
you know I remember I used to hang it at
Barco Lisa's Lounge fans of the show
know this it was named after a girl who
died in a drunk driving accident oh I
bet they do a good mozzarella stick
there her father you have no idea her
father her father put her picture in the
middle of the bar and people would toast
to her they would go to Lisa and then
they would drink and I asked this man uh
there was this crazy woman Jen who used
to come in and she would say I'm having
the fire department over because we're
having a big party and she' put all
these shaving dishes out and then nobody
would come and I would say to the
bartender I'd say what's going on they
go Jen's mentally ill she thinks she's
having a party tonight so we let her
come here and have a fake party and then
this guy George would come in who was
kind of misshapen and deformed and they
go he lives in his car uh he actually
won a scratch off this is true he had a
lot of money and then he got in with a
hooker and then she spent all his money
he lives in his car and the only place
he comes in to have a warm place is is
Lisa's Lounge um and then there were
these all these different people and I
said to the this guy uh that opened this
bar like you know
what is this place and he's like I open
you know because it was this really
weird place I was like 22 23 I should
not have been there right uh and I was
sitting there there was a woman Marge
who used to come in was old she used to
[__] herself and people would try to
take her sounds like a great place go
Mar you [__] yourself she'd go you
[__] she'd scream [__] you're all
[__] it was crazy I've told all these
stories it was all crazy um and he said
you know I opened this place so that
people would have a place to go that
don't have a place to go on a Christmas
that's awesome that's amazing and it
really and I used to think that was so
funny like I used to be like ha
haaa as you get
older as you get older and you look back
on it and it had great holiday lights
those three months yeah you know I can
smell the place December
January
um there was something really and and I
remember hearing that in scoffing at it
and being like and it was just such a
funny joke to tell you describe all the
crazy things that happened and then the
guy goes you know everyone's doing coke
and drinking and he goes I just a place
that but I will tell you this uh it I
went there on Christmas one year I was
in like a you know I was in a thing with
my family and I wanted to
go places like that are important you
know for people you know it is like a
weird thing that even though we make fun
of them and nobody nobody wants that to
be the case
with their life but then some people do
end up in that situation you know what I
mean where it's like that's there that's
like an in yeah it's like an institution
of a play It's like a revolving door
it's like Jan or whoever Marge they're
there every night yeah you're there when
you need it it's like a crutch you're
there twice when you need it but it's
there when you [__] need it and when
you think about it that's the place that
a Riri went when it wasn't Christmas
nobody wanted to know that's what fed
into the dip and that's what fed into
the family and she told everybody
tomorrow I'm not going to be here and
they said why and then she said I'm
making my di the dip I'm making my dip
so that's what fed it I'm making my dip
tomorrow you'll see me Sunday I'll be
back see you Sunday see me Sunday H Foy
Kevin Ryan the are you garbage podcast
on YouTube and patreon a podcast about
history it's like CBS CBS Sunday Morning
a podcast about time the history the how
great would it be if just I want to see
CBS Sunday Morning you guys on they're
like two gentlemen talking about Cheetos
and bath
Ms we're as the as the as the great Tim
Dylan once said we're quoting you hey
right oh my mom would love that as a pod
you know as a podcast they Chronicle a
Time Gone by a time when people Smoked
Cigarettes inside of Pizza Hut oh Andy
Rooney [__] on us
who are
they um go see these guys Pittsburgh and
pro helan Buffalo uh they're going to be
in Toronto Canada go see them at the
Royal go see them uh in Michigan go see
them in Chicago you guys gotta be show
added in Chicago show added in Chicago I
mean Chicago theater is my favorite
theater in the country Chicago is my
favorite Market to do ComEd great comedy
Town Chicago Boston it's kind of
designed for us the food the people I
love Chicago they're also in Minneapolis
Minnesota Madison Wisconsin Milwaukee
Wisconsin Sacramento San Francisco San
Jose Washington DC and of course
bringing it to a close in late December
Philadelphia Pennsylvania yeah ma'am yes
sir where you guys hail from yes very
good who cares about my I don't even
care don't come then don't come don't
come who can't want be home stay
home uh the areu garbage from patreon go
subscribe to the on YouTube as well uh
you can get all my dates if you want Tim
Dillan comedy.com we're going hard for
the next few months and we're getting
off the road in February and we've got
all kinds of other stuff happening
there's a thing that I can't talk about
that's coming out in November that I'm
not talking about all will be really may
be fun but it's not something that I'm
talking about and I stand in solidarity
with Fran drer and the
guild good night